though captain flynn killed everyone in  lylesburg i see no reason that wild  bullymung should lollygag about the  place disrespecting the memories of the  former townsfolk if you could clear the  town of them that would be most  gentlemen  the objectives on your hud pertain to  your active mission you can change your  active mission by using the mission log  in your echo device  yes  that's one area free of bully  this would be an even greater  achievement if anyone in liarsburg was  still alive to celebrate your victory  but still well done  um  will think twice about raiding peaceful  cities in the future  hopefully  please make captain flynn's death as  prolonged